[Musik]
live aus köln
der presseclub mit volker herres
herzlich willkommen schönen sonntag aus
köln schön dass sie dabei sind in 14
tagen ist bundestagswahl und auch wenn
angela merkel danach noch bis zur
bildung einer neuen regierung im amt
bleibt es endet eine ära 16 jahre hat
merkel die republik geprägt vier
wahlsiege vier koalitionsregierung
einmal mit der fdp dreimal mit den
sozialdemokraten merkel das ist auch
eine frau der superlative erste
cdu-vorsitzende erste bundeskanzlerin
erste ostdeutsche im mächtigsten amt des
geeinten deutschlands dienstälteste
regierungschef in europas und zum
schluss ein noch nie dagewesener
selbstbestimmte abschied von der macht
große themen bestimmten ihre
regierungsjahre wohlstand und sicherheit
klimaschutz atomausstieg deutschlands
rolle in einer veränderten weltordnung
und immer wieder prägten krisen die
schicksalsjahre dieser kanzlerin corona
pandemie flüchtlingspolitik die euro-
und finanzkrise und dazu merkel worte
die bleiben
wir sagen den sparerinnen und sparern
dass ihre einlagen sicher sind auch
dafür steht die bundesregierung einem
muss ganz ehrlich sagen wenn wir jetzt
anfangen uns noch einen schuldigen zu
müssen dafür dass wir in notsituationen
ein freundliches gesicht zeigen dann ist
das nicht mein land es ist ernst nehmen
sie es auch ernst seit der deutschen
einheit nein seit dem zweiten weltkrieg
gab es keine herausforderung an unser
land mehr bei der es so sehr auf unser
gemeinsames
solidarisches handeln ankommt die zeit
drängt wahnsinnig und ich kann die
ungeduld der jungen leute verstehen also
genug
ist es angesichts der objektiven
situation noch nicht aber es ist viel
passiert und mit einem höheren tempo als
1997 sozusagen auf der agenda standen
abtritt einer kanzlerin merkels bilanz
und erbe das ist unser thema heute hier
im presseclub darüber wollen wir
diskutieren und das sind heute meine
gäste tina hildebrandt arbeitet als
chefkorrespondentin im hauptstadtbüro
der wochenzeitung die zeit helge
matthiesen ist chefredakteur des general
anzeigers
pascal berichtet für das französische
wochenmagazin le und nico fried leitet
das hauptstadtbüro der süddeutschen
zeitung in berlin seien sie alle
herzlich willkommen und noch ein hinweis
für sie liebe zuschauer via stream in
diese sendung live in mehreren sozialen
netzwerken und freuen uns auch auf ihre
fragen und meinungen zu unserem heutigen
thema herfried sie haben bundeskanzlerin
angela merkel über viele jahre
journalistisch begleitet wie erleben sie
die kanzlerin derzeit am ende ihrer
amtszeit ihrer politischen karriere
also die letzten wochen und monate waren
sicher nicht leicht wir haben jetzt
jüngst er ist afghanistan erlebt was
natürlich ein herber schlag noch war und
auch die bilanz der kanzlerin natürlich
insgesamt verdüstert und der vor
anderthalb jahre corona pandemie das war
ja auch nützlichen 24 stunden 7 tage job
für frau merkel und auch für andere ich
habe schon den eindruck dass sie
erschöpft ist jetzt auch das ist jetzt
auch gut ist mit den 16 jahren das war
schon eine lange zeit und politisch ist
es sicher auch gut fürs land das jetzt
einfach ungeachtet wie man die bilanz
von frau merkel jetzt sieht einfach neue
kräfte da auch dran kommen wer auch
immer das dann sein wird die
auseinandersetzung freude erleben wir
gerade wer wird merkel beerben
bundestagswahl ist nicht mehr lange hin
wenn man auf die umfragewerte guckt
haben eine besonderheit sie tritt nicht
wieder an aber sie ist unverändert mit
abstand beliebteste politikerin in
deutschland bei den bürgerinnen und
bürgern was erklärt diese immense
beliebt hat ja ich glaube sie hat eine
eine absolut herausragende fähigkeit ist
die fähigkeit zum nicht beleidigt sein
und sie hat anders als ihre vorgänger im
grunde in gesprächen in verhandlungen es
immer darauf angelegt keine gegnerschaft
entstehen zu lassen
so persönlich zu sein den anderen
mitzudenken und das interessante ist sie
ist ja im grunde sie ist gestartet
programmatisch mit einem gewaltigen
reformprogramm hat sich dann aber von
der programmatik sehr schnell
verabschiedet weil sie gemerkt hat dass
bekommt im land nicht oder es ist dem
land nicht gut vermittelbar ist auch
ihrer partei schwer vermittelbar und hat
dann am ende eben wirklich sehr sehr
stark durch ihre person gewirkt das muss
man einfach sagen durch ihren stil durch
ihre methode durch ihr auftreten und
darin war sie schon sehr einzigartig und
sie haben vorhin gesagt was sie alles
war und bei allen diesen änderungen ist
immer ein innen hinten dran gewesen sie
haben es so nicht gesagt aber sie war
eben auch die erste frau in diesem amt
und das hat auch sehr sehr viel
verändert glaube ich ohne dass sie es
beabsichtigt hat sie ist auch da nicht
programmatisch vorgegangen aber sie hat
doch in der folge viel bewirkt was
natürlich auch an den 16 jahren liegt es
ist einfach sie hat sozusagen auch durch
die schiere dauer ihrer amtszeit
natürlich eine art von charisma
entfaltet denn am ende war sie in allen
internationalen verhandlungen immer die
die schon alle kannte und die die schon
am längsten da war ja so geht mit merkel
ja auch eine ära in europa zu enden wie
wird das denn von außen insbesondere
auch aus französischer sicht gesehen
dieser abschied ist dass wer wehmut oder
vielleicht auch frankreich war ja
manchmal auch enttäuscht von deutschland
oder auch erleichterung des teams werden
die das ist eine trauerfeier in
frankreich bei der bevölkerung bei der
regierung weiß ich nicht gleich zwischen
mehr zwiespältig aber bei der der
bevölkerung ganz dezidiert
weil ich glaube der grund dafür ist dass
merkel ist ein typus von politiker die
wir in frankreich gar nicht kennen also
sie wissen jeder politiker unser
ehemalige präsident sarkozy steht vor
gericht es gibt chancen für politiker
die jetzt vor gericht stehen es gibt
schwarzen kassen es gibt affären
sexuelle affäre und finanziellen affären
und da blickt man auf deutschland auf
diese frau die in 16 jahren keine
einzige skandal und das ist für uns
unvorstellbar und wir wünschen uns so
jemand wir sind voller bewunderung aber
ich glaube dass die franzosen so eine
kanzlerin
doch nicht genug an alle die
es ist doch zu langweilig oder zu blass
aber eine ja eine große bewunderung und
es wird für die franzosen
traurig sein glaube
ich finde dass ich meinen beitrag
geleistet habe jetzt brauche das land
etwas neues hat merkel in der letzten
woche bei einer öffentlichen
veranstaltung gesagt herr matthiesen und
schon vor jahren hat sie einmal gesagt
lang ist es her sie möchte den richtigen
zeitpunkt für den ausstieg aus der
politik finden hat sie den gefunden ich
würde sagen ja also gemessen an den
ergebnissen oder an den orten fragen die
die cdu im moment hat sicherlich nicht
dann hätte sie noch eine amtszeit mehr
gemacht würde die cdu sicherlich ganz
anders dastehen in den umfragen scholz
schickt sich also ein bisschen an der
erbe dieser großen koalition und ihrer
politik dieses pragmatismus oder dieses
durchdringenden pragmatismus zu sein das
ist ja so eine gewisse ironie der
geschichte wenn man die zurückliegenden
beiden waren sich anguckt wo die spd ja
dann in der groko immer die das kürzere
holz gezogen hat also insofern glaube
ich habe sie den richtigen moment auch
gewählt denn man kann so ein bisschen
vielleicht vergleichen auch mit dem ende
der ära kohl wo man ja auch so khol
eigentlich unangefochten groß war aber
wo man ja doch deutlich erkennen konnte
dass dringend etwas neues passieren
musste das ist glaube ich wenn man sich
die diskussion jetzt des wahlkampfs
anguckt auch in diesem fall so zu sehen
und ich glaube frau merkel hat auch
rechtzeitig erkannt dass sie nicht
diejenige ist die das jetzt noch neu
anfangen kann denn dann lassen sie uns
mal ein bisschen auf ihre art zu
regieren zu reagieren gern zu regieren
zu reagieren auch auf krisen diskutieren
sie haben alle schon angesprochen merkel
hat ja einen ganz ganz eigenen stil
gehabt und ihre amtszeit war ganz stark
geprägt ich hab's in der anmoderation
aufgezählt von krisen über krisen
finanzkrise eurokrise
flüchtlingsfrage corona pandemie trump
in den usa ein aggressives russland
unter putin ist sie vor allem eine
krisenmanagerin oder ist sie auch eine
politikerin die wenn ich sagen vision
aber doch eine idee wie sie deutschland
und deutschland rolle in der welt
verändern wollte was was dominiert wer
am ende ich habe es vorhin gesagt haben
sie hat ist gestartet mit einer idee
oder einer vision einer einer gewalt
einem gewaltigen einer gewaltigen reform
dieser bundesrepublik die sie da sie ja
von außen kam konnte sie deren defizite
vielleicht besser sehen aber sie ist
glaube ich relativ früh zu dem schluss
gekommen dass das ist den großen wurf
nicht gibt und dass man so politisch
nicht arbeiten kann sondern dass es im
grunde fenster des möglichen gibt die
muss man dann in denen muss man dann
agieren und sie hat immer für sie waren
sehr wichtig spielräume wie groß ist der
spielraum und diese spielräume die hat
sie sozusagen nicht auf sich selbst oder
aus einer idee heraus definiert sondern
aus den aus den
parametern die sie umgeben haben also
habe ich eine fraktion die mir folgt am
ende habe ich einen koalitionspartner
der mitmacht und natürlich auch habe ich
eine bevölkerung die ich noch mitnehmen
kann und am ende ist doch im grunde mehr
das bewahrende abwartende im grunde ihr
im modus gewesen dann folgt die
franzosen hätten sie würden sie nicht
wählen sie bewundern sie für ihre
skandal freiheit aber ist das einer der
gründe dass man in frankreich eher
erwarten würde jemand muss doch auch
visionen etwa von europa haben und diese
ich sag mal dieser etwas historische
rückt mathis musste inserat beschreiben
ist zu kurz gesprungen ja das ist ein
bisschen zu lahm und europa und hat sehr
gelitten darunter merkel also die
griechenland-krise sie hat gewartet und
gewartet nun hat sie forciert kannst du
sie und sie war sie hat sich sie war
sehr sehr knallharte mit den griechen
und dann kam diese berühmte rede von
emanuel makro der junge präsident ganz
anderen typus voller elan visionär
große würfe und er hat dann in der
sorbonne 2017 frisch gewählt eine eine
große plan mit 1 europäische budget ein
europäischer finanzminister und da ist
aus berlin nichts gekommen monate jahre
lang nichts
makro war dann sehr genervt und sagte ja
diese fetischismus der schwarze null das
muss man jetzt endlich abgeben und bitte
ein bisschen energie und es ist doch
wichtig vision zu haben und es ist nur
geknackt also die diese diese diese
diese diese tabus gebrochen würden mit
der pandemie als makro und merkel dann
einen gemeinsamen plan für europa um die
die die wirtschaft zu retten mit
gemeinsame schulden das war schon ein
riesenschritt für angela merkel aber ich
glaube dass man in paris sehr sehr gut
ist und man wartet jetzt man hat die
hoffnung mit den grünen weil die sehr
pro europäisch sind
die anderen auch also mein wartet jetzt
auch jemand der vielleicht ein bisschen
mehr risikofreudig ist aber alles angela
merkel sie sehr sehr sehr vorsichtig ich
glaube dass dieser stil sowohl
innenpolitisch wie auch aus und
politisch sehr stark in den ersten
jahren ihrer regierungszeit geprägt
wurde aus den umständen man darf ja nie
vergessen die umfragewerte vor der wahl
sagten ja eine schwarz gelbe koalition
voraus und am ende ist es mit hängen und
würgen eine große koalition geworden wo
sie einen enorm hohen preis zahlen
musste inhaltlich also die spd hat
erstmal bedingungen diktiert um
überhaupt mit ihr zu reden acht
ministerien usw das war natürlich nicht
das durchregieren was sie sich
vorgenommen hatte und im laufe der jahre
sind natürlich auch
weitere probleme dazu gekommen wie ein
sich immer mehr
aus flecken föderalismus das heißt auch
der bundesrat war ja immer schwieriger
strukturiert um wirklich dann auch
gemeinsam zu regieren und europa
natürlich mit unterschiedlichen
regierungen genauso und außenpolitisch
war es glaube ich ähnlich also es ist
nur ein kleines beispiel aber diese
zurückhaltung gegenüber
diesem elan in frankreich die hat das
erste mal auf frau merkel einen großen
eindruck hinterlassen als jacques chirac
sie regelrecht überrumpelt hat mit in
den kongo zu gehen damals um die wahlen
zu abzusichern mit der bundeswehr das
war ja eigentlich ihr erster
auslandseinsatz als bundeskanzlerin und
das hat da das hat sie wahnsinnig
geärgert dass sie da nicht gegenhalten
konnte und dann wiederholte sich das so
ein bisschen mit sarkozy in der
finanzkrise und je etablierte sie
natürlich war desto mehr hat sie das
dann auch von sich fern gehalten ich
will das gar nicht entschuldigen dass
sie auf makronen praktisch gar nicht
reagiert hat aber es war immer so eine
haltung lass dich da bloß nicht mehr
überrumpeln abwarten darüber nachdenken
und wenn ich dann die entscheidung
getroffen aber auch dann noch mal eine
nacht drüber schlafen das war ja die
grundsätze aber es passt nicht genau der
mangel also dass man in den momenten die
eu hat ja in den letzten jahren gewaltig
federn gelassen der praxis ist ja dann
der höhepunkt sozusagen dieser ganzen
entwicklung das nie versucht worden ist
also diese initiativen aus frankreich
aufzunehmen aber sich vielleicht auch
mal ein eigenes ziel zu setzen das ist
ja ihr cdu vorgänger kohl in der langen
ära immer wieder gelungen also solche
punkte der warnung auch in einer anderen
historischen situation frau merkel hat
das dezidiert nicht getan sondern hat
eigentlich immer pragmatisch weiter
regiert hat eben genau diese fenster des
möglichen gesucht das ist ja vielleicht
auch ein mangel den wir da sehen also wo
jetzt eben eine große baustelle bleibt
deshalb der frühere fraktionschef der
spd und verteidigungsminister 2012
gestorben peter struck mal in einem satz
formuliert der etwas spöttisch ist ja
dann gesagt sie sei eine prima
chefpiloten der man sich sehr gut an
vertrauen könne aber nur wenn einem
gleich wohin man flüge ist das eine zu
treffende charakterisierung
weiß ist böse aber auch ein bisschen
zutreffend man muss allerdings bezogen
auf europa sagen das ist natürlich auch
schwer sich da viele vorzunehmen weil es
ja nie aufhört das ist ein prozess der
auch lange vor ihrer zeit angefangen hat
sie hatte auch zu kämpfen mit
erbschaften sozusagen mit einem europa
das eine gemeinsame währung hatte aber
kein das nicht unterlegt mal durch an
gemeinsamkeiten in den politikfeldern
die dazu gehört hätten und
damit musste sie natürlich auch arbeiten
und das ist glaube ich so ein bisschen
auch das problem ihres endes ihrer
kanzlerschaft es war eigentlich nicht
mehr so richtig ein ziel in sicht wie
sie ansteuern konnte weil europa ist nie
fertig es gab auch nicht mehr irgendwie
die deutsche einheit fällt ein selten in
der show ist gab irgendwie wenig punkte
weil es ja auch immer heiße denkt vom
ende her wo man sagt da wollte sie noch
hin
ich glaube dass der punkt mit den
visionen dass sie keine vision hat der
hat auch damit zu tun also erstens
stimmt da glaube ich nicht ganz ich
glaube er hat schon eine vorstellung was
hier eigentlich gerne hätte
gerade auch was wirtschaftlichen und
sozialen aufbau in deutschland angeht
aber das hat sich schnell gemerkt dass
man das so wie sie das möchte nicht
nicht durchsetzen kann aber was sie doch
erlebt hat in ihrer regierungszeit ist
auch dass visionen
unter belastung und der enormen druck
gekommen sind zwei beispiele also die
währungsunion der euro ein gewaltiges
verdienst großartig dass wir in fast
ganz europa eine währung haben
wirtschaftlich aber auch für den
normalbürger normale bürgerin natürlich
toll aber unter druck hat man gemerkt
dass das damals als die vision umgesetzt
wurde nicht so richtig zu ende gedacht
worden ist und das zweite ist schengen
wie toll dass wir durch ganz europa
reisen können aber als die flüchtlinge
kamen haben plötzlich alle angefangen
ihre ihre grenzen zu zu machen das heißt
sie musste auch reparaturarbeiten
leisten als visionen eben sich zwar als
toll in der idee aber nicht immer
praktikabel in der umsetzung erwiesen
haben wenn man sich mal anschaut
deutschland 2021 deutschland 2005 zu
beginn ihrer kanzlerschaft das land hat
sich in einen punkten radikal verändert
ja wieviel davon geht auf merkels konto
das ist ja so ein bisschen die frage ob
sie treibe rinnen oder getriebene war
und ich glaube also ich werde den
kollegen dass ich das ja so ein bisschen
die waage hält sie hat eben am anfang
durchaus ideen gehabt aber sie hatten ja
eben sehr häufig reagieren müssen auf
die auf die dinge die da gekommen sind
aber nochmal stichwort visionen es gibt
ja durchaus dinge die da sind die jetzt
im wahlkampf eine große rolle spielen
klimapolitik zum beispiel da hat frau
merkel mal sehr stark angefangen also
mit visionen mit ideen klimakanzlerin
das war ja eines ihrer großen projekte
da ist dann irgendwann gar nichts mehr
gekommen und da ist eine große lücke
geblieben die ja laschet und die cdu im
moment gar nicht gefüllt bekommen weil
einfach die anderen so stark vor
marschiert sind und da kann man eben
sehen dass da ja doch deutlich was
liegen geblieben ist und das durchaus
eine möglichkeit da war eine vision zu
formulieren oder zu haben dann lassen
sie uns ein bisschen bei dem komplex
bleiben findet nämlich interessant weil
das ist ja ein feld von dem sie immer
gesagt hat klimapolitik ist ihr wichtig
sie hat schon in den 90er jahren ganz
früher als umweltministerin damals
kabinett kohl umwelt und klimapolitik zu
einem top thema gemacht kyoto viele
stationen ist nach grönland gereist hat
sich vor eisbergen fotografieren lassen
das ist ihr thema dazu hat sich auch
immer bekannt da machen wir mal ein
bisschen bilanzieren wie ist denn die
bilanz der sogenannten klima kanzlerin
ja die bilanz ist nicht ausreichend
würde man also oder wie sagt man
mangelhaft würde man wahrscheinlich
sagen das schulzeugnis sagt sie ja auch
selber
das ist klar das ist
zu wenig und da kommt sie natürlich mit
ihrem regierungsstil auch an wirklich an
ein problem also sie sagt ja immer
politik also und sie hat es nicht immer
gesagt falsch sondern im laufe der zeit
hat sie sich angeeignet zu sagen politik
ist die kunst des möglichen
und irgendwann kommt man natürlich bei
einem thema wie der klimapolitik an dem
punkt wo man fragen muss ist das
mögliche also das was in einer koalition
was im föderalismus was in europa
durchsetzbar ist ist das auch genug
offensichtlich nicht dann muss aber eine
demokratie natürlich auch
ideen haben oder formen entwickeln damit
umzugehen nun ist es so da ist frau
merkel glaube ich insofern auch nicht so
ganz die geeignete von ihrem politikstil
her weil sie sich dann auch damit
abfindet ihr vorgänger hat zwei
vertrauensfrage gestellt
und sie hat den 16 jahren keine gestellt
es war nie so dass sie mal ein thema so
richtig mit ihrer politischen
position in verbindung gebracht hat und
dieses amt dafür riskiert hat das war
einfach nicht ihr stil und da würde ich
sagen das wäre beim klima wirklich mal
ein punkt gewesen da hätte sie auch auf
sozusagen auf viele jahre in denen sich
schon darum gekümmert hat und dafür
engagiert hat verweisen können aber das
wollte sie nicht geteilt stimmt total
diese also sie hat sie den verkehr seite
dieser ruhigen art ist ein bisschen auch
die tatsächlichen gleichgültigkeit
gegenüber den - kosten die es dann auch
begeben hat das stimmt und ich glaube in
der klimapolitik ist die kluft zwischen
dem was sie eigentlich wusste also bei
vielen krisen musste man ja ganz schnell
auf dem neuen wissensstand kommen beim
ausgeprägtesten balkon aber im klima war
das wahrscheinlich am wenigsten so da
ist also die kluft zwischen dem was sie
wusste und dem was sie bewirken konnte
mit am größten und ich glaube dass sie
das auch wirklich schmerzt sie hat das
neulich gesagt und er ist klang schon
ehrlich ich glaube dass sie selber das
bedauert und als größtes versäumnis
wahrscheinlich ihrer kanzlerschaft
betrachtet der fried als angesprochen
gerhard schröder agenda 20 10 war weder
in der gesellschaft noch bei den
gewerkschaften und schon gar nicht in
seiner partei populär hat dabei als er
einmal davon überzeugt war es brutal
durchgesetzt wäre das etwas was bei
merkel völlig undenkbar ist dass sie
sich etwa in der klimapolitik hätte
ähnlich verhalten können also ich glaube
bei der klimapolitik ist es nicht bei
diesem
sozialreformen weil die deutschland ist
aus wird man die umfrage sieht das klima
wirklich eine große große besorgnis von
den deutschen das ist die nummer 1 auf
diese angst kann und ich vermute dass
die deutschen sie viel mehr unterstützen
hätten wenn sie große würfe in der
klimapolitik als jetzt auf dem
arbeitsmarkt wie schröder als gemahl
gesagt viel populärer als aber ich frage
mich auch die deutschen dieses wort
vision hat einen sehr negativen
beigeschmack werber dass helmut schmidt
der vision hat muss
also ist reichlich in deutschland ist
lässt nichts ein sehr positives wort und
wenn man sieht wie wie vor sich dies die
man am stabilität also wenn ich die
wahlplakate in berlin es ist nur
kontinuität stabilität kein risiko ich
weiß nicht ob die das passt nicht zu
dieser gesellschaft so große würfe und
große der erste sozialdemokratische
bundeskanzler der in der nachkriegszeit
an die macht kam hatte visionen und hieß
willy brandt aber das ist sehr lange her
ja
thema klimapolitik ich glaube gar nicht
dass das ein thema ist was ich für
solche also da will ich auch ganz bei
der kollegin das ist ein thema das was
ich für solche grundsatzfragen überhaupt
das ist ja sehr abstrakt insgesamt also
sind ja sehr abstrakte themen die wir da
haben die probleme fangen ja immer an
wenn es konkret wird also wenn ich mir
ein auto kaufen muss weil es eben keinen
benziner mehr gibt wenn ich mal eine
heizung umbauen muss wenn ich in
solarenergie auf einem hausdach
investieren muss da wird's interessant
und da sind dann plötzlich ganz andere
themen da das heißt da eine vision zu
entwickeln mit der man dann eine
polarisierung zustande bringt die im
tatsächlich zu so zu solchen jetzt also
entweder oder fragen für das ist kaum
drin denke ich mal das ist ja ein thema
was ich für kontinuierlich langfristige
weitsichtige politik eignet was man aber
ja in dem hinter verfassung so wie wir
sie haben mit dem föderalismus die
kollegen haben über die die den
föderalismus und die länder und das
zusammenspiel gesprochen schwer
umzusetzen ist und da ist es wirklich
kein funkel raus zu schlagen dass das
dann doch geht stellt sich jetzt heraus
jetzt kenne ich aber doch einen
widerspruch und den will ich mal an sie
zurückgeben wenn man nämlich das thema
wechselt wenn man auf klima guckt sie
haben gerade gesagt eigentlich in der
gesellschaft sehr populär von daher
etwas wo man sagt wer meine idee sagen
wir nicht missionen aber eine
gestalterische idee hat hat man erstmal
rückenwind vermutlich bei einem ganz
anderen thema wo absehbar war dass es
nicht populär ist hat sie umgekehrt sehr
konsequent mal gehandelt einsatz der
bleiben wird heißt wir schaffen das
merkels politik in der flüchtlingsfrage
da hat sie dinge angetan von dem sie
wusste dass sie in weiten teilen der
gesellschaft zu spalten aber doch in
vielen teilen gesellschaft auch nicht
nur populär sind wie ist das zu erklären
dass sie an einer solchen frage dann
wieder ganz anders reagiert hat das hat
natürlich diese 2015 der geschichte hat
mit visionen natürlich nichts zu tun
denn wenn wir darüber reden reden wir
immer war ein wochenende an dem merkel
sich entschlossen hat die grenzen nicht
zu schließen aber die entwicklung dass
flüchtlinge zu uns kam die hatte ja
schon lange vorher angefangen dh da war
ein unglaublicher druck drauf und sie
hatte sich ja nicht vorgenommen ganz im
gegenteil die flüchtlingspolitik zu
reformieren sondern es ist ja dann klar
geworden wir haben ein asylsystem was im
grunde vollkommen zu lasten von anderen
ländern läuft war es eigentlich
überhaupt nie unter druck da ist wieder
das thema unter druck überhaupt nicht
funktionsfähig ist und dass
hat an diesem wochenende auch reagiert
muss man sagen und sie hat dann sie ist
dann hat dann stand gehalten das stimmt
aber ehrlich gesagt hatte sie auch gar
keine andere wahl und es hat sich dann
auch so ein bisschen trotz
eingeschlichen es gab ja diesen satz den
sie vorhin zitiert haben wenn man sich
dann noch entschuldigen muss dafür dass
man ein freundliches gesicht macht ich
glaube dass einer der falschesten sätze
ihrer ihrer regierungszeit denn was da
oft gesagt worden ist was wäre denn die
alternative gewesen hätten wir dann
leute an den grenzen erschießen soll das
wir natürlich nicht die alternative
gewesen und sie hat aber zugelassen dass
der eindruck entstanden ist als gäbe es
entweder die alternative wir
kontrollieren nicht
oder wir üben gewalt aus an den grenzen
und ich glaube dass das ist nicht
richtig aber es war mit sicherheit weit
entfernt von einer ein visionäres
agieren zu sein
ist ein paar jahre her und wir wissen
wir haben viele presseclub sendung dazu
gemacht wie sehr das thema dann in den
jahren die deutsche gesellschaft
beschäftigt hat auch zu welchen
politischen fraktionen es geführt hat
jetzt mal mit abstand wie ist denn ihre
bilanz von merkels flüchtlingspolitik
also ich würde sagen dass wir es
geschafft wir schaffen das ist es eine
menge geschafft worden sicherlich also
es hat eine menge rauch an integration
stattgefunden dass man die menschen die
gekommen sind eben auch in die
gesellschaft gebracht hat in arbeit
gebracht hat was ein wichtiger punkt des
sprachkursen versorgt hat viele viele
dinge sind da gelungen aber das
grundsätzliche problem ist total
unangetastet also wenn man sich anguckt
wie europa und wie auch jetzt im
wahlkampf wieder um dieses
flüchtlingsthema um gefeiert wird um das
bloß nicht auf die tagesordnung zu
kriegen weil das schwierig werden könnte
gerade auch in der auseinandersetzung
dann mit der afg die da nach wie vor ihr
kernthema hat wenn man sieht was man
alles tut um diese diese problematik von
den europäischen grenzen fernzuhalten
die kirchen sind ja mit recht sehr sehr
kritisch im umgang wie die also mit
diesen menschen umgegangen wird dann
muss man doch sagen dass da eigentlich
außer dass man es
ja in gewisser weise totgeschlagen hat
dieses thema nicht wirklich geregelt ist
und das ist ja auch noch eine
riesengroße aufgabe die bei uns im
moment nicht thematisiert wird die aber
dringend auch eine lösung braucht ich
lerne dass die dann geben kann
also ich finde das verdienst von frau
merkel in der flüchtlingspolitik liegt
auf einer ganz bestimmten auf einem
akzent den sie zu einer bestimmten zeit
gesetzt hat es war doch so dass
die flüchtlinge über jahre in italien
angekommen sind in griechenland in
spanien auf den kanaren und in deutschen
hatten sollen nicht wer sich ziemlich
sein aber es gab es einen gewissen
gruseln man ist auf die kanaren geflogen
und hat gehofft dass am strand oder
flüchtlinge angeschwemmt wird das war
eigentlich der berührungspunkt den wir
in deutschland wir deutsche mit dieser
thematik hatten und die entscheidung von
2015 jetzt glaube ich deswegen so
besonders weil sie dieses thema zu einem
europäischen gemacht hat sie hat die
flüchtlinge ins land gelassen sie hat
auch europäisch gedacht indem sie gesagt
hat wie ich weise die nicht ab weil dann
machen die österreicher die grenze zu
die slowenen die grenze zur die kroaten
die grenzen am schluss setzten die in
griechenland im schlamm wo sie ja dann
sowieso gelandet sind jedenfalls ein
großer teil das wäre nur sehr viel mehr
gewesen hätte man die grenzen damals
zugemacht so das ist der entscheidende
punkt dazu kommt allerdings auch es ist
ein europäisches thema geworden aber bis
heute nicht gelöst das hat sie auch
nicht geschafft und da hat sie auch eine
mitverantwortung weil sie es natürlich
sehr brutal versucht hat also nicht nur
durch diese entscheidung sondern auch in
den ersten wochen hat man ja versucht
mit dieser berühmten
mehrheitsentscheidung in brüssel die
osteuropäer praktisch zu zwingen das
mitzumachen und das hat den widerstand
er erhöhte und zu den problemen geführt
die wir bis heute haben das eigentlich
es ein großteil der länder in europa
geht die mit dieser thematik nichts zu
tun haben will trägt
sich kein widerspruch zu lassen sie das
auf einen anderen aspekt gucken merkel
war nicht nur oder ist gar noch
bundeskanzlerin sie war auch lange lange
zeit cdu parteivorsitzende und sie hat
diese partei in den letzten 16 jahren
sicher auch geprägt wie keine andere
kein anderer aber wie hat sie die union
die cdu
verändert marc klingler fragt auf
twitter
er hat schon eine meinung wie viel
schuld trägt merkel an der desaströsen
verfassung der union
also sie trägt zumindest einige
verantwortung will ich sagen die frühere
bildungsministerin und und merkel
vertraute annette schavan hat neulich
mal in einer sendung gesagt merkel habe
anders als schröder nie ihre partei
verloren hat er an die hartz-iv-reform
erinnert und da würde ich sagen das ist
glaube ich nicht ganz richtig denn es
hat in dem einen fall hat es eine
abspaltung gegeben oder in oder fange
man bei der spd hat es eine spaltung in
der partei gegeben meine cdu hat es eine
eine art von abspaltung gegeben aber die
cdu ist schon in diesen merkel jahren
irgendwo ein bisschen heimatlos geworden
und merkel hat glaube ich über lange
jahre das interesse an der partei auch
ein bisschen verloren es war ihre
machtbasis weil sie war in erster linie
kanzlerin ich glaube das geht jedem
kanzler so das kann man ja immer wieder
beobachten das machtzentrum ist dann im
kanzleramt und nicht in der
parteizentrale und da hat sie aber auch
wenig unternommen um da sowas kann ja
ein kanzler auch gar nicht leisten oder
eine kanzlerin aber wenig unternommen um
da leute zu installieren köpfe zu
installieren die das hätten machen
können oder zuzulassen man hat angela
merkel vorgeworfen dass sie die türe des
bundestags für die idee breit geöffnet
hatte dass sie ihre partei gesprengt hat
dass ein teil ihrer wähler sind so afd
und ich sehe das mit anderen augen also
ich glaube dass durch deutschland sich
einfach normalisiert hat weil die afd
ist nicht immer rational
12 40 prozent bei uns steht marie le pen
nächstes jahr sind wahlen in frankreich
und sie wird ganz bestimmt indem
stichwahl und es ist für makro wackelig
also für den zweiten wahrscheinlich wäre
das makro sehr wackelig also die kraft
der afg ist nicht die frage der us
national noch nicht aber es war wundert
ein wunder dass es in diesem land diese
restriktion das hat unten gebrodelt und
die flüchtlingskrise hat das noch zum zu
der oberfläche gebracht aber da ist
deutschland auch jetzt ein populistische
bewegung hat ist eigentlich normal sie
sagen ist normal
dass
ein eintrag auf twitter meyer schreibt
kann man frau merkel die entstehung ganz
in ihrem sinne der fc in die schuhe
schieben angesichts all der neuen
rechtsextremen parteien in europa also
sage ich dann so so dies
ist das ergebnis der politik also dass
da waren das werde ich verstehe ja bei
ihnen was ist das ergebnis ihrer politik
das ist die existenz der auf die ich
glaube dass merkel nicht zur spaltung
deutschlands beigetragen im gegenteil
ich glaube dass sie diese spaltung
aufgehalten hat vielleicht wenn man das
so als normalisierung
sieht und diese diese polarisierung die
wir jetzt haben ist doch zum großen teil
das ergebnis davon dass milieus
verschwinden und auch das
sozusagen eine gemeinsame öffentlichkeit
verschwunden ist die aufspaltung der
öffentlichkeit in viele kanäle in unter
interessen ich glaube dass merkel das
relativ lange überdeckt hat sogar es ist
so es ist ein ein unvermeidbares leben
ergebnis ihrer methode gewesen aber ich
würde deswegen finde ich so wollte wie
schuld oder so es gibt natürlich einen
zusammenhang die frage ist nun ob man
das vorschreibt oder als vorwurf
formuliert und die navis sind
unausweichlich keine schulden ein
bisschen anders insofern also ich glaube
sie akzeptiert sogar ihre verantwortung
dafür dass die afg vor allem diesen
zweiten schuba sie war ja nach der
finanzkrise eurokrise eigentlich schon
sehr klein wieder und durch die
flüchtlingspolitik ist ja noch mal hoch
gekommen und es gibt dieses einrücken
satz von frau merkel aus einem interview
mit den kollegen der frankfurter
allgemeinen sonntagszeitung da wurde sie
gefragt was ist denn mit dem satz und
franz josef strauß rechts von der union
darf es keine demokratisch legitimierte
partei geben und dann sagt sie der gilt
aber nur so lange wie man als cdu dafür
nicht seine eigenen werte verraten muss
das hätten wir es ins meine worte
ein wörtliches zitat von frau merkel
aber gemeint hat sie hätte wir in der
flüchtlingspolitik unsere eigenen werte
als christliche partei verraten dann
wäre das falsch gewesen nur um die afg
zu verhindern insofern ja sie hat sie in
kauf genommen aber nochmal noch mal ein
schritt zurück weil ich diesen diese
auswirkung auf die cdu die ist
eigentlich spannend sind nicht nur das
kann man eine wahl kann es jetzt ja auch
beobachten dass die cdu ja so ein
bisschen unter dieser diesen
pragmatismus der die politik bestimmt
hat dieser dieser ziel wenn zielsetzung
selbst mittelfristige ziele waren ära
deutlich leidet denn sie kriegt ja kein
thema platziert und ist es auch wenig da
und das scheint mir doch so ein kleines
problem zu sein dass man in der cdu sich
auf diese situation ohne frau merkel
antreten zu müssen gar nicht vorbereitet
hat an der stelle also keine
programmatische arbeit gemacht hat nicht
neue kapsel installiert hat bei der spd
kann man das durchaus sehen die haben
das sehr intensiv gemacht was man davon
hält es vielleicht eine andere frage die
grünen haben das sehr intensiv getan die
cdu hat gesagt machterhalt und irgendwie
geht schon weiter und der pragmatismus
reicht in dieser situation eben nicht
und da ist eine große lücke entstanden
und das hat eben auch nicht mehr auch
dafür von verantwortung zu reden und
nicht von schuld aber da ist auch in der
parteiführung zu wenig zusammengelaufen
da gibt es einen punkt den man glaube
ich ganz klar fest machen kann also
diesen vorwurf dass die partei
ausgedünnt ist würde ich beiden seiten
machen ja die der cdu hat es auch gut
gefallen die man an der macht zu bleiben
die hat er auch jetzt nicht großen pop
sich jetzt da und programmatischen zu
kümmern der entscheidende fehler war die
diese entscheidung den parteivorsitz
abzugeben weil sie hat einfach also frau
merkel hat einfach falsch eingeschätzt
dass diese drei jahre eine parallelität
von kanzlerin und wem auch immer als
parteichef dass das nicht funktioniert
weil ich meine frau kramp karrenbauer
hat er versucht egal wie man jetzt die
richtung findet in diese die cdu
bringen wollte aber am ende war die frau
im kanzleramt die stärkere und das hat
natürlich auch den schaden verursacht
den wir jetzt insbesondere in der cdu
sehen aber ich weiß gar nicht ob es ist
wirklich falsch eingeschätzt hat ich
glaube sie hat das ja auch nicht gemacht
also sie hatte starken druck gemacht und
deswegen das selbstbestimmte ist an der
stelle auch ein bisschen eingeschränkt
und sie hat ja auch selbst gesagt das
ist ein großes experiment sie hofft dass
das auch schöne seiten entfaltet ich
glaub ihre partei findet das jetzt nicht
so schön passt dieses gescheut und war
sich nicht ganz klar sind wir vor einer
bundestagswahl die union steht in
umfragen muss man mal sagen sind
momentaufnahmen ist noch kein ergebnis
muss man immer betonen wähler sind sehr
volatil viele sind noch unentschieden
aber sie steht in umfragen derzeit bei
der sonntagsfrage
sehr miserabel oder ungewohnt schlechter
so schlecht eigentlich noch nie in ihrer
geschichte wie viel verantwortung trägt
merkel dafür wenn es bei dieser
bundestagswahl für die union ganz bitter
ausgeht
das ist schwer zu beantworten weil sie
tritt nicht an und das ist eine
situation die die cdu seit einigen
monaten kennt auf die man sich hätte
vorbereiten können und das scheint mir
ja nicht ausreichend passiert zu sein
also wieder in der kandidatenauswahl war
man besonders glücklich und hat auch
nicht besonders kommunikativ nicht
besonders gut und glücklich agiert man
hat eben wie gesagt programmatisch sich
nicht aufgeladen man hat an vielen
stellen glaube ich auch nicht die neuen
leute platziert die man bräuchte
die man nicht hat wie hat sie sich
treffen und um ihr erbe gekümmert ich
glaube schon ja ich glaube eher das was
nico fried gesagt dass es so zu sagen da
ist der hauptteil der verantwortung das
in ihrer partei das aufgebürdet hat die
kanzlerschaft in der weise von den
parteivorsitz abzutrennen für den
wahlkampf hat sie natürlich jetzt keine
verantwortung also dafür dass armin
laschet irgendwie lacht dass die cdu
wahnsinnig schlechter plakate aufhängen
das ist natürlich alles nicht ihre
schulter kann man kann ich schon aber
andersrum ist es sehr interessant sie
wollte sich heraushalten sie hat es auch
noch mal explizit angekündigt bei einem
wahlkampfauftritt dass das eine ausnahme
ist und das hat sich jetzt total
verändert die not ist riesig und jetzt
muss wird sich frau merkel mit rein und
dieser auftritt im bundestag wo sie da
gesagt hat eigentlich darf es hier nur
eine regierung laschet geben ist
natürlich also ehrlich gesagt ist eine
katastrophe für laschet wie auch für
merkel lasse der immer gesagt hat 16
jahre merkel das war gut aber jetzt muss
was anderes kommen ja mehr märz und
bezeugt er muss sich jetzt plötzlich von
frau merkel helfen lassen und frau
merkel hilft ihm indem sie im bundestag
sagte es geht um eine regierung der
stabilität maß und mitte all die
attribute die wir mit frau merkel
verbinden also damit hatte hat sie ihm
keinen gefallen getan und sich selber
aber auch nicht
das liegt doch es würde dieses land gut
um eine art begrenzung zu haben
vielleicht dann hätte man zeit neue
gipfel zu aber ich sage heute ich sag
das mal ist sie haben immer was die
leute twittern offenbar haben sie den
siebten sinn weil das taucht genau auf
die begrenzung der legislaturperiode ist
absolut richtig und ich denke wieso
nicht auch für bundestagsabgeordnete
schreibt etwa sebastian auf twitter und
wir mehrere solche einträge sind zwei
amtszeiten nicht eigentlich genug sehr
witzig sie hat vier französischen
präsidenten sarkozy
roland und jetzt makro und sie war die
ganze zeit da und in frankreich gibt es
dieses wort liga schießen das heißt es
raus werfen es muss was neues ist muss
man bleibt nicht um das rauswerfen will
um das haus ersten tencel und jetzt
sieht man es ist sehr interessant zu
beobachten dass alle machen merkel nach
also schulz ist eine kopie der ist ja
laschet auch obwohl er sich distanzieren
wollte sie haben es gerade gesagt er der
macht da berbalk nicht aber sie ist eine
frau und ich bin auch diese karte und
man hat nicht das gefühl dass dieses
land sich jetzt befreiten sie und
irgendwas anderes probieren das stimmt
eine frage muss noch gestellt werden
viele kanzler schafften sind dann mit
irgendeinem begriff verbunden das ist
sozusagen für die geschichtsbücher willy
brandts ostpolitik fällt jedem sofort
ein helmut kohl auch ganz einfach
wiedervereinigung gerhard schröder
sozialreformen was bleibt von merkel
womit wird man sie nach ihrem ende als
kanzlerin verbinden
schwierig es ist schwierig was bleiben
wird ist glaube ich dass es nur eine
frage für historiker die in 20 jahren
glaube ich schlauer beantwortet wird als
heute
aber es ist glaube ich so dass dieses
thema der krisen und des
krisenmanagements das ist ja das was
auch an helmut schmidt so ein bisschen
dran geblieben ist dass der terrorismus
in erster linie bei jesus ja die krise
insgesamt wir wissen nicht was kommt
also die rückschau auf frau merkel wird
ja irgendwann mal in 10 15 jahren dann
form annehmen und die perspektive von
dann ist dann wenn dann schlimmere
krisen gekommen sind wird sie sicherlich
anders bewertet vielleicht ist es das
letzte goldene die letzte goldene phase
der bundesrepublik wir wissen das nicht
aber krise habe ich sicherlich ein
begriff der bleichen wird die grosse
krisenbewältiger in die aber vielleicht
bei anderen großen themen wir haben sie
besprochen klimawandel oder so dann doch
zu kurz gesprungen ist ich glaube dass
sie wird sicher in verbindung macht
werden mit stabilität
und sie wird natürlich auch immer da ich
kann es noch mal wiederholen aber es ist
eine große sache sie wird immer die
erste bundeskanzlerin bleiben und sehen
hat damit im grunde für alle frauen die
beweislast umgekehrt also außerdem sie
es gestartet mit kann die das und jetzt
gibt es sozusagen für alle frauen steht
diese frage nicht mehr im raum sondern
eher er im grunde die frage warum sollte
die das nicht können und das ist schon
irgendwie eine große eine große sache
oder die erste frau aus dem in die
elster erste kanzlerin aus dem osten
das hätte niemand für möglich gehalten
nach dem mauerfall niemand also
ostdeutschland ist überrumpelt worden
sony weist von der in westdeutschland
und es eine ostdeutsche an der spitze
der macht kommt das ist schon und sie
hat sich auf eine wand in dieser woche
der letzten woche bei einer öffentlichen
veranstaltung auch zum ersten mal als
feministin in einem gewissen sinne
gesagt und das ist ja auch interessant
und sie hat an dem punkt sagen sie
wirklich die gesellschaft für frauen
enorm modine damit ackermänner würde ich
sagen und auch das im windschatten
sozusagen
vielen dank für die diskussion wir sind
am ende der sendung angelangt das liebe
zuschauer war der presse hier im ersten
wir freuen uns wenn sie in den sozialen
netzwerken weiter mit uns diskutieren
mögen etwa beim presseclub account auf
twitter hier geht's jetzt weiter mit dem
europamagazin heute abend im ersten das
trial ganz wichtig da wird es noch
einmal darum gehen wie sich die drei
aspiranten für das kanzleramt schlagen
und im presseclub nachgefragt den gibt
es jetzt wie immer auf phoenix und im
radio auf wdr5 wir danken für ihr
interesse und wünschen ihnen noch einen
angenehmen sonntag macht es gut und
hoffentlich bis zum nächsten mal und
tschüss
[Musik]
willkommen zurück im presseclub ich
begrüße sie zum presseclub nachgefragt
hier auf phoenix und dem radio auf wdr5
abtritt einer kanzlerin merkels die lanz
und erbe das ist das thema unserer runde
darüber haben wir diskutiert im
presseclub und jetzt sind sie dran mit
ihren fragen an meine gäste und wir
gehen zunächst nach detmold ulf
kramer ist am telefon ralf cramer seien
sie gegrüßt hallo
wirklichen schaden zu bewahren werden
aktive auf uns zukommt und
wir erleben jetzt dass unsere
waldökosystem mit scherben und dass wir
einfach in die situation kommen wir
nicht befragt werden da sie hat mir
wirklich
fertig machen können die fünf letzten
drei jahren das was die bisher
umgesetzten handeln und billiger letzten
den kommenden politiker mehrerer kaum
noch zu bewältigen ist und das
schlimmste ist dass ihr musste ich einen
nachfolger hatte es gibt einmal
verstanden hat wie kaum werke was gibt
ihnen aktive bedeutet für die zukunft
unseres landes und der welt und ich
frage mich und nur gerade bekommen warum
hat sie nur gehandelt wird und alle
karten bilder erklärung hat immer die
industrie gestützt aber nie unsere
lebensgrundlagen und
vielen dank herr löw kann man sie sind
selber landwirt nicht ja doch meinen
gesamten wald verloren dauer lang die
zehntausende andere waldbauern die für
jahrzehnte kein einkommen mehr abend
werden die bieterin komplett weg und die
laubwälder sind schwer krank das ist
unsere aktuelle situation neben dieser
einen wirklichen unfall waren
flutkatastrophe in den urin web
deutschland
aktive 2000 eigentlich bedeutet werden
vielen dank herr kramer und ihnen alles
gute wer möchte auf diesem jahr doch
deutlichen vorwurf reagieren also wir
haben es ja vorhin gesprochen das ist
nicht das glanzstück dieser
kanzlerschaft die klimapolitik aber ich
würde jetzt auch nicht so weit gehen
frau merkel alleine für das sterben der
wälder im sauerland verantwortlich zu
machen so dramatisch dass er sich da
überhaupt nicht darüber lustig machen
aber natürlich ist es eine
gesellschaftliche entwicklung die wir
über jahrzehnte ja auch schon gesehen
haben und die widerstände gegen den
klimaschutz sind natürlich auch große
seen groß in der industrie das hat der
zuschauer gerade gesagt sie sind aber
auch bei jedem einzelnen groß ich tue
mich auch leicht hier die frau merkel zu
kritisieren und daher fahre ich mit
meinem verbrenner wieder durch berlin
jeder muss sich ja da auch selber
umstellen also ja sie hat zu wenig
gemacht sie ist nicht ins risiko
gegangen
ins also ins ultimative risiko aber es
ist natürlich schon auch eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche verantwortung
der presse club kommt aus köln die
nächste anruferin aus düsseldorf
brigitte siemens ist am telefon frau
siemens seien sie gegrüßt hallo guten
tag in die runde
ich habe auch keine frage für vor märkte
sondern nur eine anmerkung
ich möchte sagen dass frau merkel dass
wir sie wahrscheinlich noch irgendwann
noch mal vermissen werden und nicht nur
in deutschland sondern wahrscheinlich
weltweit denn sie war ja überall sehr
beliebt und ich wünsche ihr für ihren
ruhestand
alles liebe und gute und wir waren eine
gute kanzlerin vielen dank frau siemens
für ihre einschätzung ich glaube das
lassen wir mal so stehen sie haben
vorhin gesagt wie auf die franzosen
reagieren also die welt des angesprochen
worden dass wir als kommentare mal
stehen und kommt zum nächsten anruf dass
es heidemarie hall bord aus pressig frau
hat ja
bis auf die anfangszeiten sonst so eine
wunderbare kanzlerin die vier hatten wir
noch nie ich bin jetzt rentner reden und
mir als rentnerin gegen deutschland sehr
gut also ich kann überhaupt nicht
glauben und ich hoffe und wünsche frau
merkel viel gesundheit und ich hoffe
dass auch der nächste kanzler alle
renten der denkt nicht
die den staat kaputt machen oder
irgendwie
also in den abgrund treiben wollen
sondern wir sind andere leute und ich
hoffe dass der nächste kanzlerin kommt
auf die industrie aufpasst und nicht
alles zulässt was sie wirklich für die
umwelt nicht mehr brauchen denn es wird
in der nächsten zeit nicht geben
vielen dank frei wird und ihnen alles
gute wir spüren an den anderen fahren
wie populär wir haben in der sendung
darüber gesprochen frau merkel
unverändert doch in der bevölkerung ist
aber es gibt glaube ich auch kritische
fragen
reinhard schneider ist am telefon
wiederum aus düsseldorf der anruf herr
schneider
guten tag in die runde frau merkel hat
fast alles richtig gemacht wie man
beantworten kann seine fragen die später
kommen da kann man sich noch nicht dazu
äußern
aber frau merkel steht in vollbesitz der
geistigen kräften ich denke die physik
literatur bei quantenphysik ist die
zerstrittene und dies auch auf dem
laufenden
ich kann nicht nachvollziehen dass mal
ein solcher frau die laut erfolgreich
war ist er tun wird
da haben wir offenbar ein tonproblemen
was herr schneider angeht aber ich kann
ihnen verraten was er wissen wollte er
nämlich gesagt bei aller bewunderung
warum ist frau merkel nicht in der lage
gewesen ihre nachfolge so zu regeln dass
jemand mit aussicht auf erfolg jetzt
antreten kann für die union na ja sie
hat selber immer gesagt ich finde sie
hat da einen punkt wir leben nicht in
der monarchie oder ich glaube der
winfried kretschmann hat das gesagt und
in dem sinne kann und muss einen kanzler
auch seine nachfolge nicht regeln ihre
was sie für die partei bewirbt oder
nicht bewirkt habe das haben haben wir
besprochen das kann man glaube ich auch
kritisieren aber diese nachfolgeregelung
die finde ich da hatte kann sie sich zu
recht auf die demokratie berufen darf
ich noch eine sache zu der höheren
vorhersagen über und damit nicht zu
harmonisch würde ich gerne auch frau
merkel ihren ruhestand und auch der
hörerin ich hoffe nur dass beim nächsten
kanzler auch die junge generation sich
so zufrieden äußern kann denn das ist
glaube ich etwas was wir ein bisschen
unterbelichtet haben
die iss schon die politik war schon sehr
an den mittelalten und älteren
orientiert und da wäre glaube ich auch
mehr gegangen thema das wir noch nicht
diskutiert habe ich will es auch nochmal
kurz aufgehalten danke dass sie es
ansprechen gerade wenn es war eine
rentnerin die sich geäußert hat muss man
sagen wir haben auch schon presseclub
sendungen dazu gemacht dass insbesondere
das rentensystem auch angesichts der
demografischen entwicklung vor riesigen
herausforderungen steht und egal wer die
nächste bundesregierung bildet hier
einen reformbedarf ist der immens ist
also wenn man so will auch eine
hinterlassenschaft wie man kritisch
sehen kann ein anderer punkt der auch im
netz
auftauchte aber auch bei unseren
anrufern ist etwas worüber wir auch noch
nicht gesprochen haben jens otto fragt
auf youtube ist der rückstand in der
digitalisierung die soziale spaltung und
der investitionsstau federführend bei
merkels vermächtnis und ich glaube dazu
haben wir auch ein anrufer der sich
genau zum stichwort digitalisierung
äußern möchte das ist ralf mertens
ausfahren herr mertens grüße sie
[Musik]
doch eigentlich schon am anfang ihrer
kanzlerschaft immer wieder ziele
vorgegeben hat jedes mal nicht erreicht
wurden andere themen sind zb
die kap das tragen das gesundheitssystem
und der katastrophenschutz hat auch sehr
gelitten wie man jetzt gerade bei der
flugkatastrophe sehen kann die runde
dazu vielen dank herr mertens wer möchte
kann man also bei der digitalisierung
glaube ich ist hinterletzte in den
letzten monaten corona eine ganze menge
geschafft worden da sicherlich etwas
voran gegangen das große manko glaube
ich was man sehen kann sind ist die
digitalisierung in dem ganzen
öffentlichen bereich also in den
rathäusern in den schulen in den
behörden in all diesen dingen walter
viel zu wenig zusammen läuft und weil
man einfach merkt wie schwach und wie
wenig strukturiert das ganze aufgestellt
wird und ich glaube dass die
riesenbaustelle das ist aber nichts
glaube ich was man frau merkel zu
rechnen muss sondern was eben eher bei
den kommunen bei den ländern gehe auf
diesen mittleren ebenen liegt und wo der
bund glaube ich impulse setzen kann aber
die digital pakt für die schulen wo man
merken kann dass das eigentlich dann
auch verpufft wenn man das tut bei den
anderen themen
sind sicherlich auch defizite da aber
ich glaube weiter digitalisierung ist
frau merkel nicht so sehr im fokus
der nächste anruf kommt aus wiesloch
peter sawicki ist am telefon seien sie
gegrüßt herrscher witzke und ihre
anmerkung zu unserer debatte hier ja
runde
man mag ist als ich das bei kanzlerin
und
außenputz weltpolitik vertrieb gut
gekümmert aber um und in deutschland
sehr wenig gekümmert hat ich gehe von
den mieten ausgeht von endres und maus
ist die
digitalisierung aus
wir haben die chance sich wenig um uns
selber gekümmert
hillenbrand die wirklich gerne
danke ihnen ich würde sagen sie hat
natürlich indem sie sich gut um die
weltpolitik gekümmert hat auch gut um
uns gekümmert denn das ist ja nicht ganz
unwichtig wie es uns so geht aber
ansonsten bin ich will ich ihnen
zustimmen das sagen wir mal der mit
jeder krise ist der sockel des
liegengebliebenen etwas größer geworden
und es ist doch einiges liegen geblieben
und am ende hat die kraft nicht mehr
gereicht wahrscheinlich den nico fried
hat gesagt
warum das war von die frage warum hat
sie sich da nicht noch mal aufgerafft
und ich finde gerade bei dem thema
digitalisierung da würde ich allerdings
schon ein großes versäumnis auch bei der
kanzlerin selbst sehen denn das ist
wirklich ein feld da kann man dann auch
irgendwann sich nicht mehr und da stimme
ich ihnen zu auch nicht mehr auf
zuständigkeiten was heißt rausreden wir
haben den föderalismus aber es ist dann
in der bilanz irgendwann will das auch
keiner mehr hören dass da irgendwie
länder und die kommunen zuständig sind
und man kann natürlich als bunt und als
bundeskanzler zumal oder kanzlerin meint
man kann da natürlich prioritäten
einfordern und setzen das ist schon das
ist schon so
so jetzt muss ich im moment warten weil
das tablet gerade die anrufe sortiert
damit sie es verstehen und jetzt sind
sie sortiert und ich kann nach hannover
gehen zu gerhard arndt
erahnt seien sie gegrüßt
ein fest der demokratie
in der welt und deutschland
natürlich nicht alles gut negativpunkte
was ich bei ihr bemängeln muss
sie hat ihre politik was ihre absicht
ist eigentlich nie richtig erklärt
fehler von gerber der listen nach der
letzten bundestagswahl
hätte sie dafür klingen müssen ihre
politik erklären zu müssen
möglichen falls wenn es nicht gepasst
hätte hätte die cdu csu auch in eine
minderheitsregierung geben müssen
vielen dank herr an
stichwort kommunikation den bürgern
erklären was sagen sie dazu
hat sie hinreichend erläutert die ihre
manchmal ja auch politischen wollten ich
gebe zu dass ich da glaube ich eine
minderheitenmeinung vertreten weil ich
dieses defizit immer nicht so gesehen
habe jedenfalls nicht das bemühen ist zu
tun ob sie in der lage war es wirklich
dann auch zu vermitteln in seiner
mitreißenden reden oder so dass es dann
noch mal der andere frage es ist ja
keine wirklich große rede in erinnerung
geblieben haben es auch am anfang
gesehen mehr so diese einzelnen
versatzstücke so drei wort sätze wir
schaffen das und es ist ernst aber
wenn ich zum beispiel an die
flüchtlingspolitik mehr in rheda ist sie
zweimal zu einem wege gegangen sie haben
mehrere pressekonferenzen gemacht im
sommer eine vor der sommerpause damit
eine nach der sommerpause usw also
dieses defizit kann kann ich nicht
erkennen
wir haben gesprochen über die komplexe
regierungssituation in deutschland das
ist sicher anders als in frankreich
föderales land bundesländer viele ebenen
politisch europa kommt auch noch dazu
also eine kanzlerin fried hat
insbesondere betont kann nicht
durchregieren wir haben aber auch dazu
einträge und anrufe ich will das
zusammenfassen die in die frage münden
letztendlich hat sie zu wenig von ihrer
richtlinienkompetenz gebrauch gemacht
vielleicht nicht nur in der sozusagen
diktion des grundgesetzes sondern auch
von der die eine kanzlerin japan macht
figur allemal eine die 16 jahre sich im
umfeld hat zu sagen bei schröder hätte
mal gesagt was da jetzt wirds aber mal
so gemacht digitalisierung klima hat sie
davon zu wenig gebrauch gemacht
es ist nicht so sehr geliebt und sie gut
gesehen in deutschland wenn sie denken
dann die pandemie dass ihr mann marco
ist geschafft hat die leute wochenlang
zu hause einsperren zu lassen man könnte
nicht aus dem haus ohne so ein papier
eine erklärung
maske überall und die franzosen haben
das geschluckt was ich gucke nicht viele
normalerweise aber die haben es
geschluckt und die kanzlerin hat das
nicht gemacht es war sehr es war eine
sehr komfortable pandemie hier es gab
sehr wenn ihr selber einige
restriktionen und ich glaube dass das
hätte sie nicht die deutschen hätten das
nicht akzeptiert
komischerweise weil man will das
klischee sagt dass die franzosen zur
regel nicht rebellisch und sofort auf
die straße gehen und die autoritäten
also sie sagen sie sie hatte auch keine
große chance energischer was der politik
zu betreiben
ich glaube dass das man da ja so wie der
begriff demokratie sehr sehr ernst
genommen hier die kollegen fragen wir
jetzt nicht mehr aus einem ganz
einfachen grund weil man nämlich auch am
ende unserer runde presseclub
nachgefragt angekommen sind ich bedanke
mich sehr herzlich bei ihnen noch mal
bei meinen gästen und bei ihnen für ihr
interesse und wünsche ihnen noch einen
angenehmen sonntag machen sie es gut und
bleiben sie uns gewogen und hoffentlich
bis zum nächsten mal in schuss
[Musik]